你看我们每个人的生活里边或多或少
你都会经历一些创伤
或许是情感上的伤害
也或许是事业上的失败
甚至是一些深深的自我否定
那你看这些创伤
它会往往伴随我们一生
让我们觉得自己总是很倒霉
生活总是不顺
心里积压着无法释怀的痛苦
那么如何消除这些创伤呢
这个问题
我相信很多同学都在寻求答案
今天我们就来讨论一下这个话题
欢迎来到
松明讲心理
首先很多人都会有这么一个感觉
为什么我的人生总是这么的不顺利
或者是我总是失败
为什么我那么努力却没有改变
有这些问题
往往都是源自于
内心的创伤
你知不知道
创伤给我们最大的影响
不仅是让我们痛苦
而是它在潜意识里边
控制着我们的行为和情绪
我们经常会发现自己
无缘无故的感觉到失落
感觉到焦虑
或者感觉到无助
甚至有时候会对自己的人生产生否定
那这些负面情绪到底是怎么来的呢
它们就很有可能是
我们早年经历的一些创伤
或者是一些未被解决的痛苦
那这些创伤它会逐渐的积累
形成我们内心深处的这么一个阴影
我们对这些创伤的反应
有时候是逃避
有时候反复的去回想痛苦的经历
甚至我们会在无意识当中
反复让自己体验这种失败的情绪
那么如何消除这些创伤呢
其实消除创伤
并不意味着
你要把过去的一切都抹去
而是通过一种方式
让我们与内心的创伤
能够和平的相处
甚至学会感恩它的存在
让它不再成为我们的负担
那么有一种非常有效的方法
催眠的技巧
你可以通过这种技巧
与自己的潜意识进行一个对话
探索创伤的根源并进行化解
简单的一些步骤
就可以帮你实现
这种内心的这么一个转变
我举个例子
你比方说
我们可以请潜意识呈现出
你心中的失败
到底是一个什么样的
那么这个我们在咨询里边
也叫做
意向        对话
你可以让这个失败
从一个模糊的一个形状
或者是一个面具
或者是你可以把它形容成一个石头
它的重量
它的大小
它的颜色
它和你的距离
你都可以由自己来决定
那么接着
你在心中去感受
这个失败给你带来的痛苦
你会发现这个失败的形象
并不是那么的令人害怕大家理解吗
就是你可以开始和它对话
你可能会说你让我很痛苦
但是你也在帮助我成长
你在内心当中感谢它
甚至把它当做是自己的朋友
在这种意向对话的过程里边
哎你可能就会发现自己
并不想完全摆脱失败的情绪
因为这个情绪会带给你某种
我们叫做
二级获益
简单来说
二级获益就是指啊
当我们处于某种不良状态的时候
它反而能带给我们某种额外的好处
你比方说失败哎
它反而让你感觉到了
自己得到了他人更多的关心和照顾
甚至可以从中获得某些特殊的
这么一个待遇
对吧这种潜在的好处
可能会让你不愿意放下失败的情绪
这种心态非常的常见
你可能会不自觉的
保持这种失败的状态
因为它能够让你从他人那
获得更多的关注和关怀
然而长期处于这种状态
会让你错失自己真正想要的人生啊
所以有时候你是时候让自己意识到
失败和痛苦带来的不是长久的安慰
而是让你停滞不前
你需要跳出这个恶性循环
给自己一个新的选择
那么接下来我们来聊一聊
如何才能真正的面对这些创伤
消除它们对我们的影响
很多时候
我们之所以
不能放下过去的痛苦
是因为我们一直在对抗它
我们觉得自己不应该遭遇这些创伤
你可能会认为
它们给我们带来了太多的不幸
于是你看很多人不断的抗拒
内心深处的痛苦也会因此得不到释放
但事实上
接纳创伤
治疗的第一步
你不需要一味的逃避
应该正视它
只有当你接受创伤的存在
才能从它的身上去汲取力量
进而走向自我的这么一个修复
接纳创伤并不意味着认同它同学们
而是接受它曾经发生的事实
然后通过它让自己变得更强大
每一个创伤的经历
都是你成长的一部分
如果没有这些经历
你就无法变得更加的成熟和智慧
你要问自己啊
这段痛苦的经历究竟教会了我什么
它如何让我变得更好
所以你需要的是将焦点
从创伤本身
转移到你未来的生活上
你去思考一下
这段经历如何可以转换
成为我成长的这么一个动力
也许你无法改变生活
但是你可以决定如何去面对未来呀
你比方说
你可以通过设定一些小的目标
来逐步走出这种失败的阴影
证明自己也是一个有能力改变现状的
给自己一个机会
让自己从小的成功当中积累信心
逐步的迈向一个更大的成功
无论是工作上的突破
还是你个人生活当中的成长
我跟你说
每一个小小的进步
都是你走向自我修复的重要一步
如果说
你感觉到自己的生活一直没有突破
或者始终无法放下过去的创伤
最好的方法
就是给自己设定一个具体的目标
你比方说
你可以设定一个一年以内实现的目标
可能是完成一项你一直想做的一件事
或者是实现一个梦想
那通过设定这个目标
你能够激励自己
逐步的去改变这个现状
证明自己不仅可以面对创伤
还能够从中得到成长
那这个过程的关键就是两个字
行            动
你需要通过实际的行动来告诉自己
我有能力改变
未来是属于我的
无论这目标有多小
只要你为之付出的努力
它就能成为改变命运的起点
所以大家记住
创伤虽然无法改变
但你如何去面对创伤
才是决定了你未来的命运
失落
负           担
焦虑
无助
自我否定